[MUSIC]
That is an impala, or
as we call it in South Africa a springbok,
I shot one dead when I was
ten years old and I hated it.
I hated seeing such a beautiful
wild animal die because of me.
Hunting clearly wasn't for me, so
my first hunt was also my last.
Since then Africa's majestic
wildlife has become of almost
spiritual importance to me.
There's something quite liberating about
looking into the eyes of an animal that
could kill you.
And it's humbling to see
an elephant family interact and
think that perhaps it's us who
have much to learn from them.
So there is no cause I feel stronger
about than conservation, and
then something happened that really upped
the stakes, Cecil the lion, remember that?
A global news storm, a hunt gone wrong,
the wrong lion shot,
a famous lion, Cecil,
star of BBC documentaries.
The shooter, an American dentist
called Walter Palmer, the reaction.
>> Walter fucking Palmer.
>> How fucking demented
this mother fucker is.
>> May you fucking burn to death.
>> I want somebody to
take fucking revenge.
>> What would happen [INAUDIBLE].
>> Sick son of a bitch.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> I know, that was ugly, but
welcome to the divisive
world of trophy hunting.
Every year thousands of foreigners
go on organized hunts in Africa,
they take home with them the animal
head or trophy to hang on their wall.
They pay tens or
even hundreds of thousands of dollars for
these trips, the costs include a fee for
the animal shot,
as well as professional hunting guides,
trackers, accommodation, and travel costs.
Now it's easy to hate this, but what
if I told you that hunting can be good,
that it can help protect Africa's
wildlife, preserving scenes like this.
I know, counterintuitive right,
and today I'm not going to
convince you not to hate photos
like this one if you already do.
And I'm also not going to get into
a debate about the ethics of killing
animals, whether they be lions or
chickens.
Emotionally, I wish we
didn't need hunting, but
objectively right now regulated
trophy hunting is a good thing for
Africa, there are three reasons why,
let's start.
First, resources,
conservation doesn't happen by accident,
it's an intentional,
managed process requiring resources.
Huge areas of land, fences, water
supplies, managers and ecologists, and
squads of armed rangers to
protect against illegal poaching,
this all costs money in a part of
the world where people are very poor.
It's hard to expect people who live like
this to care about nature conservation
before their basic human needs have been
met, food, shelter, financial security.
Which brings us to the second point,
the biggest killer of wildlife by far,
anywhere in the world,
is human encroachment.
Wild habitats are destroyed to create
farmland, animals are hunted for meat,
remember in Africa many people eat protein
starved diets and cannot afford meat.
Farmers in America might complain
about the occasional wolf,
well try being a farmer in Africa,
hyenas, leopards, pythons, crocodiles.
Elephants are shot because
they trample crops,
lions killed because they eat livestock.
Hippos offer danger when they're alive,
but
can feed a whole village if they're dead.
And this problem is only getting much
bigger, Africa's population is exploding,
look at this chart, epic performance
from Africa over the next 100 years.
So there has to be an economic
incentive to conserve wildlife,
and hunting can provide it.
By setting hunting quotas below
the animal population growth rate and
by targeting older male animals,
hunting can be both sustainable and
profitable and that gives landowners
an incentive to convert from
commercial farming to game reserves.
It works, since regulated rhino hunting
was introduced in South Africa,
the white rhino population
has grown tenfold.
The best example is Namibia's Community
Conservancy Program, Namibia's gone and
given ownership and management of
wild land over to local communities.
Income from hunting and
tourism goes directly into conservation
expenses, local communities gain income,
jobs, meat, these conservancies now
cover an area larger than England.
Okay, so then what about the other option
for generating income, photo tourism?
I long for the day when tourism
can carry the weight of sustaining
Africa's wild areas but
we're a long way off from that.
Tourism is a large industry but
it's concentrated in a few areas,
it needs to be safe and
close to airports, whereas trophy hunters
will go anywhere and
pay top dollar to pursue their passion.
Let's look again at those Namibian
conservancies, they're clustered up in
the north of the country and on this map
they've been color coded to show which of
them are currently profitable, green,
and which are loss making, red.
Now let's simulate what would happen
if we removed the benefits of hunting,
the map changes green to red.
And those red areas, they'd go back to
what they were 30 years ago, cattle farms,
land over-grazed to dust, so you see,
hunting is sustaining remote wild places
that many people have never heard of.
And now, now hunting can help pay for
protection against a new crisis,
the rampant illegal wildlife trade
driven by demand from China and Vietnam
for rhino horn, ivory, and lion bone.
Rhino horn is now worth more
than cocaine or gold, and
that means these incredible animals
having their faces hacked off,
sometimes while they're still alive, and
this must never be okay,
we have to be better than this.
Unlike hunting, this killing is
unregulated, unsustainable, and
totally out of control, and we need every
conservation tool available to prevent it.
Now not all hunting is good,
as in any system there are problems and
abuses, and
canned hunting is one of those.
Animals, often lions, bred in captivity so
that they can be shot in staged hunts,
these lions are tame,
they can't even hunt for themselves.
They're taken away from their mothers
when they're three days old so
that the mothers will breed again and
again, real lions are raised by their
mothers for at least 18 months.
Hunters need to take responsibility for
stopping this because it's their
dollars that keep it going.
Other hunting systems may be run
with incompetence or corruption,
meaning the benefits don't
flow to local people.
But this means we need
to seek improvement,
not shut the whole thing down,
and right now this is real.
Since Cecil the lion, 45 airlines
have banned the transport of animal
trophies and several Western governments
are considering import bans,
the whole thing is under threat.
And as we saw in Namibia, a knee-jerk,
uninformed ban could lead to
the loss of huge areas of wild land.
And then, what about the 184,000 people
who live on Namibia's conservancies,
who's thinking of them?
What about African citizens of
other countries who live with and
support trophy hunting?
Almost all the anti-hunting
backlash comes from wealthy people.
It's so ironic, it sometimes feels
like the two things that Facebook
warriors around the world care about when
it comes to Africa are human poverty and
wild animals, yet
the anti-hunting campaign could hurt
both human poverty and wild animals.
So I dislike hunting, but
the majesty of Africa's wildlife has
been one of the highlights of my life,
I must do what I can to preserve it for
future generations.
That means making hard and
informed choices and
it may also mean having to cooperate and
coexist with those who are different from
me, those whom I may never understand,
in pursuit of a shared goal.
I hope that this talk has
helped you to see some of
the complexities of conservation and
how hunting can play a role.
And finally, I really hope that
everyone in this room one day has
the chance to come to Africa,
have the holiday of a lifetime,
live to the rhythm of nature,
shoot with a camera, not with a gun.
You will support jobs and
conservation, and
if enough of you do that one day
we won't need to kill to protect.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]